About an hour ago, Donald Trump
addressed the American people. This
follows um an address uh from Prime
Minister Albanese of Australia, Jewish
people as well as Prime Minister Stormer
to the British people. And in both
speeches by Stormer and Albanese, they
said they said to the to the people, "We
know that fuel prices, gas prices are
going up um and we should expect more
pain, but we will do as much as we can
to ens to ensure that your uh wallet is
not too impacted." Donald Trump in his
address to the American people basically
said that uh this war will continue and
um
America may start to bomb energy and oil
infrastructure of Iran. Okay, so let's
listen to a few of his words.
Our economy is strong and improving by
the day and it will soon be roaring back
like never before. It will top the
levels that it was a month ago. I've
made clear from the beginning of
Operation Epic Fury that we will
continue until our objectives are fully
achieved. Thanks to the progress we've
made, I can say tonight that we are on
track to complete all of America's
military objectives shortly. Very
shortly, we are going to hit them
extremely hard over the next two to
three weeks. We're going to bring them
back to the stone ages where they
belong.
>> Okay, so he's basically saying that
we're winning this war and we're we will
bomb them to the stone ages, which tells
us he's actually not winning this war.
Okay. Now, um I also want to look at
another
um
person who is Peter Hex
>> new strategic map.
>> So remember this war in Iran, it's not
ending. In fact, many people people
believe it's only starting to ramp up.
So there are rumors that Donald Trump
has has already authorized the use of
ground forces and so we could see an
invasion of Iran as early as this
weekend but certainly definitely um this
month. Okay. But while America is
fighting this war in Iran, this is the
secretary of war Peter Hegv and he's
announced that America will control all
North America.
from Greenland to the Gulf of America to
the Panama Canal and its surrounding
countries. At the Department of War, we
call this strategic map the greater
North America. Why? Because every
sovereign nation and territory north of
the equator from Greenland to Ecuador
and from Alaska to Guyana is not part of
the global south.
is the security perimeter in this great
neighborhood that we all live in.
>> Okay. So basically what he's saying is
we will enforce the Monroe Doctrine in
North America. So it sounds very strange
to people in that Donald Trump is
fighting this war in Iran that's not
really winnable. the same time he is uh
being aggressive in North America. He's
seeking fights with Canada, with
Denmark, over Greenland, with Colombia,
with Mexico, with Cuba. In fact, he's
embarrassing Cuba right now and people
expect possibly an invasion of Cuba very
soon. So, people just think that Donald
Trump is all over the place and he's
idiotic. Okay, so this is Iran and
everyone says that a ground invasion of
Iran would be stupid because it is much
too large to invade. Right now America
America has only about 50,000 troops in
the Middle East and the geography, the
terrain makes it very hard to control.
Okay. So, you have these mountains, the
Zagos mountains, which allows for the
Iranians to hide and conduct guerrilla
warfare and use drone strikes and
artillery strikes. Um, and then you have
the desert, which ma which makes it very
hard to cross. Okay. So, even if the
Americans were to attack from here, from
Iraq, um, they would have to face the
mountains. If they were attacked from
Pakistan, from the east, they would have
to face deserts. Okay. And if they were
to attack from the south, they would
face all these mountains and also you're
far away from Tran, which is ultimately
your your objective. Okay. So there are
there's lots of conversations about what
the Americans are trying to do right
now. The consensus seems to be the
Americans first want to control the shoo
in order to elevate the strain on the
global economy. Okay. But as you can see
from this map, first of all, the
straight, it's not very wide and it's
very close to the Iranian coastline in
the mountains, so it's easy to attack
from. And
um
there are these and then the Iranians
can put mines all around the straight as
well. So what everyone tells us is that
an invasion of Iran would just be
idiotic. At the same time, the Americans
need to free up the shoo and allow for
maritime navigation in order to
stabilize the global uh economy. Okay.
Um already we're seeing lots of signs
that America is preparing for a long
long war. So there are already 50,000
troops in the Middle East and a lot of
them are will be uh deployed against
Iran. But also there's a letter from
Leonard Anderson to reserves telling
them to to to say telling them we must
get ready to deploy fight and win. Okay.
So not only have they sent 50,000 troops
to Middle East, but they're preparing to
call the reserves as well. Okay. So this
seems as though America is preparing for
total war.
uh poly market is a very interesting
place to understand how global events
will turn out. Okay. And so there are
three indicators that in fact a war is
coming, a ground invasion is coming.
First of all, the peace pizza index is
exploding. What does this mean? It means
that in the Pentagon um when they are
preparing to launch a ground invasion,
they need to work overtime and so they
call for pizza. Okay? Uh and and so
pizza deliveries are going up. Gay bars
are empty. Okay. So when people are, you
know, don't have much to do, they go and
you know go on dates. The last is that
people are making bets, large bets that
a grand invasion will
happen. Okay, so these are people people
who have inside information and so they
go on poly market and make make a bet
that this will happen knowing it will
happen. So this guy bet $200,000 that an
a grand invasion will happen and if it
turns out an a grand invasion does
happen, he will win over a million
dollar. Okay, so these are three very
good indicators that a grand invasion
has been approved and it will happen
very very soon.
Okay. Um Donald Trump himself
has said many many things. Okay. So
he said that you know what if we leave
the Middle East it's not our problem we
don't really care okay and he also says
that
hey NATO
it's your responsibility to open the
street of Hamus because we told you so
and because you need the oil and of
course NATO is angry at Donald Trump
because previously Donald Trump
threatened to take over Greenland. Okay,
so everything's Donald Trump is just a
He doesn't plan ahead because
before this war in Iran where he needs
the help of NATO, he was pissing off
NATO by threat to take over Greenland.
So Donald Trump is over the place. He's
just a right?
Um but
let's just
assume okay that the ground invasion
goes ahead. What will happen? Well, as I
as I predicted before, if a ground
invasion were to go ahead, first of all,
America would lose this war because a
ground invasion would fail and the
Iranians are fully prepared for a ground
invasion. Second of all, if America
loses war, the American empire would die
because be forced out of the Middle
East. they would they would lose the
petro dollar and the US dollar as a
global reserve currency. The third thing
is the global economy would collapse. So
clearly Donald Trump is the worst
president in human history
and he's a complete buffoon.
Right?
Okay.
But let's put our thinking caps on.
Okay. Let's use game theory and say, but
what if for some strange reason, Donald
Trump wants to lose his war in Iran?
What if he wants the American empire to
collapse?
What if Donald Trump wants to destroy
the global economy? Then he'd be a
genius. Right.
Right.
He's a because he's going to
destroy the American empire. But if he
actually wants to destroy the American
empire, then the man is the greatest
American president ever. Okay. Okay. So,
we're going to have a fun class today
and we're going to make the argument
that in fact Donald Trump is a genius.
That in fact all this chaos
um is purposeful.
That there's actually a plan behind all
this. Okay, that's the argument I want
to make to you uh today. Okay, so what
is the plan? What is going on here? All
right, so first thing to notice is that
the world gets 20%.
Okay, 20%
of its oil from the Middle East. Okay,
primarily going to
um
East Asia. So India gets about 6% of its
oil from the Middle East. Japan gets 75%
of its oil from the Middle East. So East
Asia is heavily dependent on Middle East
oil. Okay. But as you can see, it also
goes to Europe as well and then also to
the United States. All right. So the
world is dependent on the GCC oil. If
this war continues, if ground forces are
used, then all the oil from the Middle
East collapses and JP Morgan has come
out and said that by midappril the world
will run out of oil. Okay, so this is a
disaster for the world,
but it's not it's just much more than
energy needs. Okay. So this by because
Iran is constraining movement in the
straight of home moves. We're seeing
we're seeing seven major uh shortages.
Okay. So yes, we know oil and LG
um are being stopped. Okay. But actually
the problem is much worse because look
at phosphate, ammonium, sulfur, ura.
This is food production.
Okay. primarily used for fertilizers.
In other words, if this war persists,
not only will countries run out of
energy, they'll also run out of food.
Okay.
Also, look at this. Helium
and sulfur are used for what? They're
used for um semiconductors. the
production of semiconductors use um
um helium and sulfuric acid in the
production of semiconductors which leads
to AI. Okay. So in other words this
um war in the Middle East it's it's
impacting everything in the market
economy.
Okay. It's if this war continues the
global economy could collapse.
But again, we're we're making the
assumption that Donald Trump is a genius
and this is all part of his big plan.
Okay. So, what is his plan?
All right.
So, okay, we know that there's a lot of
oil in the
Middle East. Okay. But, you know, oil is
not as rare as people think it is.
There's also a lot of oil in Canada.
Venezuela
has
the world's
um largest oil reserves. Okay. Uh Russia
also has a lot of oil. So in other
words,
if the shoo is closed, if this war in
the GC continues, it doesn't mean the
world no longer has oil. All it means is
the world is now much more dependent on
North America
and Russia for
oil.
And so the global economy now shifts
over to North America and to Russia.
Okay? So in other words, the United
States starts a stupid war
in the GCC in the Middle East. It can't
possibly win, but it still benefits.
Because now the world is much more
dependent on North America. Okay. Why is
Venezuela important? Because America
just took over Venezuela in January.
Okay. And and look and look, Canada has
a lot of oil and Trump is threatening to
take over
Canada.
Okay? So
now let's let's look at who needs the
oil.
Well, this map tells you that if you're
in the red, you you consume more oil
than you export. And who are these
countries? Well, they're Europe,
okay?
And they are East Asia
as well as Australia.
Okay. So, yes, I understand Donald Trump
is an idiot. Yes, I understand that he's
going to lose his war in the Middle
East. Yes, I understand he's going to
destroy the global economy, but for some
strange reason, he benefits and the
United States benefits because now
Europe and China,
Japan, Australia, they're much more
dependent on North America for
resources, for food, for energy.
Okay.
All right, food. Okay, so nitrogen is
important for fertilizers. Okay, you
need nitrogen for fertilizers. Um, and
as you can and what this map tells you
is that if you are in the blue or the
light blue, it means you produce more
nitrogen than you need. So, you exported
it. If you are not in a blue, then
you're kind of screwed. Okay. So
basically um this area this area
especially uh this area okay uh Europe
as some parts of Europe okay so now they
need more nitrogen and again before they
were getting a lot of nitrogen ammonia
from the Middle East and now where where
are they forced to get the nitrogen
from here and from here.
Okay. So again,
yes, I know Donald Trump's losing this
war in the Middle East, but in the long
term, America stands to benefit,
right? Last thing, last thing I want to
look at is water. Okay, water is
important because water tells us which
areas are the most stable. Basically, if
you have a if you have a lot of water,
you're less prone to conflict. But if
you don't have that much water, then
you're prone to conflict. Okay? So, we
looked at we look at so if you're in a
um dark blue, you're good. Okay? Nothing
to worry about. If you are in the light
blue, you are in a lot of trouble. Okay?
So, we look at this area, North America,
pretty stable because lots and lots of
fresh water. Okay? If you look at
Russia, pretty stable, lots and lots of
um uh fresh water. But if you're Africa,
you're in a lot of trouble. If you're
Europe, you're in a lot of trouble. If
you are Middle East, you're in a lot of
trouble. If you are um Southeast Asia,
uh you are not in that much trouble, but
you are in some trouble. Okay. So we we
already see how this map tells us where
in the future basically Russia and the
United States, North America are the
most stable parts of the world with the
most resources and therefore they are
the most resilient, the most stable.
Okay. But if you go to Africa,
Europe, Middle East, Southeast Asia,
these are points of conflict in the
world. So we can expect these places to
become much more unstable over time. So
in other words, all the United States
and Russia have have to do is maintain
stability and then export resources to
these places. And guess what? if they
and then they make a lot of money for
themselves. Okay, so again, I understand
Donald Trump's an idiot. I understand
this war in the Middle East is stupid,
but from a long-term game theory
perspective,
the United States wins from this
disaster, from a long-term perspective.
Okay,
now you look at this map, you think,
well, China's pretty good, too, right?
Like, China has a lot of fresh water.
The problem with with China though is
this.
China
sits on a lot of fresh water that
Southeast Asia and India depends on.
Okay? So a lot of water is in the
Tibetan plateau. It flows downstream
into India and in Southeast Asia. If
there were a drought
using game theory, we can suspect that
China might want to keep the water for
itself, right? In which case, Southeast
Asia and India would be very angry.
Okay. So, this is a potential flash
point that we have to watch out for.
Okay. So it seems like China is stable
but
the surrounding areas are not so stable
and so China will be dragged into a
conflict.
Okay.
All right.
So let's summarize what we've learned so
far. So these are the countries with the
most oil reserves. Okay. Venezuela,
uh, Saudi Arabia, Iran, Canada, Iraq,
UAE, Kuwait, United States, Russia. Uh,
okay. All right. Now, what's interesting
about this is is this
this war in the Middle East is going to
knock out the oil production of Saudi
Arabia, of Iran, of Iraq, of UAE, of
Kuwait, which leaves what? which leaves
uh oh Venezuela, Canada, and the United
States. Okay. North America and Russia.
Okay.
Now then look, let's look at let's look
at who has to buy oil, right? Let's look
at who who buys oil.
Well, the United States consumes a lot
of oil, but again, it has its own supply
of oil. China needs to import a lot of
its oil needs. Okay. So, China imports
about 7 75% of its um uh oil needs.
India, Russia, Saudi Arabia, Brazil,
Japan, South Korea. Okay. Um Germany.
All right. So, China, India, Japan,
South Korea imports a lot of oil. And
where does it get its oil from? The
Middle East. Right? So if he can't get
his oil from the Middle East, then these
four countries, China, India, Japan, and
South Korea need will need it to get to
get the oil either from United States or
Russia. Okay? And why does this matter?
Well, well, look, let's look at this.
Let's look at who owns
the most US treasuries. Basically, if
you own a lot of US treasuries, it means
that you are financing American debt.
America right now is $39 trillion in
debt. That's a lot of money. But as long
as people continue buy US debt, as long
as people want to buy US treasuries,
it's not a problem. Okay, it's a Ponty
scheme.
Okay,
so let's look at this. Who are the
biggest um holders of US debt? Japan,
China, right?
Um
Taiwan, Singapore, Hong Kong, India.
Okay, so this is all Asia and we already
said
that Asia needs a lot of oil from the
Middle East, right? Now let let's look
at uh others. United Kingdom a second.
Okay, Cayman Islands is basically just
Europe as well. It's um it's a mining
mining operation. Okay, Belgium,
Luxembourg, Fran, Canada, France,
Ireland, Switzerland. These countries
are Europe
and again where do we say
most oil from the GC go? It goes to
either e Asia or Europe. And now because
of the stupid war in the Middle East,
Asia and Europe are now forced to buy
oil from either Russia or the United
States. And this is important. Okay,
this is important because previously
there's a fear that these countries
would stop buying US treasuries because
America is too heavily in debt. The
American American economy is too much of
a Ponzi scheme. So there's this great
fear that Europe and Asia would would
move away from the US dollar and more
towards Swiss Franks or gold. Okay. Now
because Europe and Asia need fertilizer,
they need energy from the United States
and of America.
United States no longer has to worry
about its debt. Okay.
All right. The $39 trillion debt, not a
problem because the entire world is
dependent on North America for
resources. The policy can keep on going.
So again, Donald Trump is an idiot, but
he's so stupid. He's become a genius.
Okay.
All right. Now, you're like, "Wait, but
Donald Trump's an idiot. Where would he
get this where would he get this idea
from? How would he know how to do this?"
And the answer is because Putin has
already proven that the strategy works
in Ukraine. Okay? So, let me show you
how. Okay, so this is the war in
Ukraine. And as you can see, um the dark
red are areas in which Russia is
contesting territory. The light red,
sorry, the pink are areas
in which Russia wants to gain territory.
As you can see, Russia still has a long
way to go and we're already four or five
years into this war,
which means that this war can go on for
another 10, 20 years. It's a very slow
grind
and it's good for Russia. Yes, I know
that Russia is losing a lot of soldiers
and I know that the Russian economy is
suffering, but this long war of
attrition is good for Russia. Why? Well,
because first of all, what it does is
it allows Russia to industrialize its
economy.
Okay? It allows it uh it allows Russia
to center its economy around war
production. Okay? So the red um as you
can see is total
industry.
Okay. And as you can see it's been going
up since the war started. All right.
Overall industry is been going up as as
well. Unfortunately industries that are
not dominated by the military that have
no war purpose is actually going down.
Okay. So it seems as though the entire
Russian economy is being restructured
for total war for a long war and that is
the purpose that is the goal.
Okay. So again the pink are
um military industries the blue are
civilian industries and as you can see
the blue sorry the um pink completely
dominate the blue and the trend is
increasing meaning it is possible in
four or five years time Russia is
primarily a war economy
industrializing
to produce war weapons. Okay, munitions.
Uh specifically
drones. Okay, these are drones.
All right, so
um
before at the be at the beginning of the
war,
Russia was dependent on Iran for drones.
Okay. But then what happened over time
is that
um Russia
started to have its own domestic
production. Okay. So imports from Iran
have stayed constant and then domestic
production has gone way up which tells
us that the Russian economy is
industrializing
for the production of drones
and Russia is preparing to fight a long
long war.
Now, not only uh can Russia produce its
own drones for the war, but it can also
export its drones to Iran to fight
against the Americans.
Okay? And so you're like, wait a minute
here. So Russia is switching its entire
economy to war production, which means
that Russia will always fight wars.
is is is that what Russia is planning?
And the answer is yes, it is. Okay. And
so let let me explain why Russia is
planning this. This is something called
the third Rome plan. Okay? And this
comes from the 1996 book, sorry, 1996
book,
Foundations of Geopolitics. Okay. by
actor Dugan who I think is one of the
smartest uh geopolitical political
thinkers alive today. Okay. And his
argument is this. His argument is this
unipolar moment of American dominance.
Um it's going to fade away because it's
too much focus on secularism,
individualism, liberalism. And these
ideas break apart community. These ideas
are antihuman. So eventually western
society, western civilization will
collapse because its values are abhorent
and when it collapses this this gives
opportunity for Moscow to become the
third Rome. Okay. Uh we'll talk more
about this in the future. But what's
brilliant about Dugan is he recognizes
that when the world collapses, all
Russia has to do is stay stable and
resilient. As long as it stays together,
unified, cohesive, it'll be fine. Okay?
Because as this global order collapses,
as global economy collapses, every other
society will face eternal collapse such
as United States. Okay? So he he
predicts civil war in the United States
as left and right go to war against each
other. Okay? He predicts uh collapse of
China. He predicts collapse of um the
Middle East. He predicts collapse of
Europe. Okay. So all these places are
collapsing. Basically if you are the
main pillar of the global economy, you
are much more susceptible to collapse
than if you are not. Okay. What so what
Dugan says is this. Okay. All right. So
the strategy is first of all Russia
needs to stay coherent. It needs to
defend its territory. It needs to unify
its people through nationalism, through
religion, okay, through faith. And then
what Russia needs to do is figure out
allies that that would support the
Russian outlook. And this and these
allies could include Japan.
Okay.
Uh Vietnam, India, Iran.
Okay. And then by combining their
forces, they become a trading block onto
themselves. This is an age of nuclear
weapons. You don't want to go to war
against each other, but this is also an
age of collapse. So, as long as you're
able to stay coherent, as long as you're
able to defend your borders, then you'll
come out ahead. Okay? So that's the idea
of moving towards war because war has a
power to unify the imagination and the
beliefs of the people in your nation.
Right? So using war in order to increase
the nationalism, the religion of your
society which will allow you to weather
the storm better. Okay? So that is the
grand vision of a dugan and in my
opinion he is absolutely correct and
Russia is moving towards this by
invading Ukraine. All right. So the
Ukraine invasion was not a response to
NATO. The Ukraine invasion was to
implement this grand vision for the
creation of the third Rome to allow
Russia to survive the coming collapse of
the global order better than anyone
else. Okay?
And so by taking over Ukraine, you now
control onethird of the world's
carbohydrates and a lot of the world's
energy. Right? Once you control Ukraine
in the Black Sea, you're now able to
export your energy and your food to
Africa, to the Middle East, to Europe,
to Asia. Okay,
so that's the grand vision for Russia.
And again, in my opinion, this makes a
lot of sense. The world is collapsing
and so you have to um build a fortress.
You have to be self-sufficient in order
to weather the storm.
So given this America is like well we
can do the same thing. Okay. And so the
grand plan for America is something
called
the technate. Okay.
Sorry. There something we'll discuss
more later on. Okay. But first first I I
want to introduce this this idea to you.
The technate. And the technique is very
simple. It's the idea that you know what
yes the world is going into chaos. The
world is collapsing, but um North
America is self-sufficient,
right? So these past few months, Donald
Trump has been has picking picking a
fight with uh Denmark over Greenland,
right? He's been threatening Canada.
He's been threatening Mexico. He's been
threatening uh Colombia. He's think he's
taking over Venezuela. He's been uh
threatening Cuba. He's been threatening
Honduras, Nicawaga. Why is he doing
this? because they're all part of the
grand vision for greater North America.
Okay. What Peter Hexf calls greater
North America,
the technate. All right. And this is
response to Moscow's third Rome. If
Moscow is going to build this grand
alliance in order to weather a storm and
America has no choice but to also build
this grand alliance as well in order to
protect itself in this coming storm. All
right. So what Donald Trump has
recognized is that Putin is right. The
world is collapsing. There's nothing we
can do to save the world. So let's just
accelerate it in a way that allows
America to benefit from this collapse.
Okay. So, by collapsing the GCC, by
collapsing the Middle East, you make
Asia and Europe now dependent on
American
um North American energy and fertilizer
exports. And this allows you the
resources, the motivation to create the
technate, okay, this self-sufficient
um economy. Okay?
Does it make sense? All right. Okay.
All right.
So, let us summarize. Okay. So in
um November sorry September 11th 1991
George HW Bush he responds to the fall
of the Berlin wall the collapse of of of
so new phrase called the new world order
and there are three major pillars to the
idea of the new world order. Okay. The
first idea is that America will become
the financial capital of the world. We
America will offshore uh resources and
manufacturing to other places and then
America will focus primarily on finance
making Wall Street the center of the
world. Okay.
The other idea is the idea of secular
multiculturalism.
So the world is divided but what can
unite everyone is the love of money, the
love of consumerism. So if we just focus
on making money and buying things, then
the world will be forever at peace.
Okay? And so we have to let go of
borders. We have to let go of community.
We have to let go of identity and focus
more on consumerism. Okay? And the and
the last idea is global domination where
in order for global trade to happen,
America will provide security for all.
No one has to fight it anymore because
America will guarantee global peace. If
anyone rises to challenge this order,
pass Americana, the America will go
destroy it.
Okay.
So these are the three main pillars of
the new world order as announced by
George HW Bush on September 11th uh
1991. Okay.
Trump world order is a response to this
new world order. Basically what Trump is
saying and what what he's been saying
for a long time is why should America
pay for the defense of other nations?
Why should America
have to be uh the consumer of last
resort for everyone? Why are the
American why are Americans paying for
everything so that Europeans can have
their welfare and their pension?
Everyone's taking advantage of America
and it's destroying America. So let us
change the new order to the Trump world
order. Okay? And how do you do that?
where you move America from a focus on
finance to a focus on resources and
manufacturing. Okay, basically you you
believe the world is going to permanent
war and so you provide the resources and
manufacturing in order to facilitate
this world war. Meanwhile, America is
has become fortress of America. It can
it can hide behind its um fortress kind
of fortress and it's protected by two
oceans, right? Okay. So this makes
sense. Multiculturalism doesn't work. It
leads to stupidity such as DEI, woke
politics, transgenderism, it's all
Let's focus on what makes us
proud to be Americans, which is
Christian nationalism. Okay? Our love of
the white race, our nation, and God.
Okay? So no more of this
multiculturalism, no more immigration,
no more open borders, no more democratic
party. Let's just focus on being
Christian nationalists. Okay? Love the
United States, love of Christianity,
love of um the white race. And the last
idea is why should America pay to
protect the world? Screw Pax Americana.
Let's just do MAGA. Okay, what is MAGA?
MAGA is national rejuvenation.
Let's make America great again by
rebuilding America's manufacturing
industry by exploiting re the infinite
resources that God has given America in
order to make sure every American um has
a decent life. Okay.
All right. So again, I understand Trump
is an idiot. Trump has launched America
into this stupid war in the Middle East.
Trump has pissed off NATO. Trump has
pissed off all of America's allies.
So, he's a
But if the goal was to destroy the
American empire, destroy the global
economy and rebuild America for the
benefit of Americans, then Trump is a
genius and he may go down in history as
America's greatest president. Okay. All
right. Um, any questions?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, uh, my first question is you
mentioned that the the the Donald Trump
or like pudding they they think that the
world like the whole system will
collapse inev inevitable. But like how
why like if this uh Ukraine war doesn't
happen or if this Iran war won't happen,
how will the world economy collapsed?
Like okay.
Okay, that's a really good question.
Okay, so um both Putin and Trump know
that the world will collapse and the
question is how do they know this? And
the answer is because it's so obvious.
Okay.
So, um for the longest time,
America
started um what America did was
it basically
um after World War II, it
lent money to Europe and Japan so that
Europe and Japan can buy manufactured
goods from America. Okay. And this was
good for America
um because it created a lot of jobs and
Americans were productive. But then over
time Americans became very lazy and so
they made the Europeans and the Japanese
do the work specifically Germany. And
then America started to
um
be
the consumer. Okay. So then America
started to spend more money than it
made. Okay, before it made more money
than it spent and lent this money to
Europe and Japan. But then over time
this reverse itself.
Okay. And then what happened was that
America started to shift its
manufacturing to China.
And so China is like let's let me do all
the work for you America.
and um I'll do it for really cheaply and
I'll borrow money from you. Sorry. So
I'll get I'll lend you the money to do
it. Okay. So what's happening is that
America is becoming lazy
in debt
and corrupt.
Okay? Because the entire world was
basically
um working for America for very little
money. So Americans sly have to work.
And this led to massive inequality
in America which led to political
corruption
which led to an oligarchy. Okay? So
don't think of America as a democracy.
Think of it as an oligarchy.
And so when that happens when only a few
people benefit from the system then the
American people get really pissed. And
so they affect they elected for they
elected Donald Trump. Okay. And why did
Donald Trump get elected? because he
understood intuitively this system does
not work. It cannot it cannot
hold. It cannot be stable for too long.
It's going to collapse eventually. Okay.
The question then is when will collapse
and who will benefit from the collapse?
And Donald Trump's like okay then let's
control the collapse so that my friends
and I can benefit the most from this
collapse. Okay. And Donald Trump has two
sets of friends. The first are are the
Christians, okay? Christian
evangelicals, basically the fanatics who
support Israel as well as the AI,
Silicon Valley.
All right? So, we learn about the idea
of elite over production. Okay? But the
idea is that as society collapses,
declines,
the elites start to compete against
themselves for resources. And so right
now the elite are the finance people
and the new elite okay the counter
elites are the AI people okay artificial
intelligent and it's something we'll
discuss later on okay but I but I
introduce you to the idea but basically
the idea is that America is a is a house
of cards it's a Ponzi scheme it's
corrupt it's unequal it's lazy it's in
decline so it's so it's going to fall
apart sooner or later okay but the
question then is like how do you manage
this decline? How do you control this
decline in a way that allows you you and
your friends to benefit the most? Okay.
And that's why Donald Trump started this
war in the Middle East. Because by
starting this war in the Middle East,
you're accelerating the process of
decline in America. And therefore,
you're able to help transform America
from one that from from an economy
that's based on finance to one that's
based on resource exportation and then
manufacturing. Okay? Does that make
sense? All right. Any more questions?
>> So I have one last questions about the
explanations of this war like before we
explain it in the religious perspectives
and how does this like this explanation
connect to the explan explanation today?
>> Okay. All right. Yeah, that's a really
good question. Okay. So the thing to
understand about war is that there are
different factors at play. Okay. So
before we went went into esquetological
factor.
All right. Now I explain explain to you
the geopolitical
or the um um economic. Okay. But there's
also the historical
or hubris.
Right? And what you need what you need
need to recognize about history is that
often all three things converge
together. Okay? Because what is
religion? Religion is a memory, a
long-lost memory of our ancient past
told through myths and stories. So
there's truth to religion because it's
basing a lot of its ideas through
personal experience, through history.
Okay, from thousands of years ago,
right? And geopolitics, economics drives
historical forces. So another way,
another way of understanding this is
that often all these different factors
are aligned together. This something
we'll discuss more later on. Okay.
All right. And so why do I look at
different factors, different vectors?
And the answer is because I make
predictions. And if I'm able to analyze
an event using esquetology, geopolitics,
and history, and they align together,
then I can make a pretty accurate
prediction that this will happen. I
don't know when it will happen. I mean,
I know who the players are, but I'm
pretty sure this event will happen.
Okay, does that make sense? Okay, great.
All right, so uh we'll continue this
next week.